on the subject of sizing there are some
CSS units that you may not have heard of
but which are now really widely
supported how about if you want an image
that responsively cover the whole height
of the viewport now you can always do
that by setting the height of the image
to one hundred percent but that only
works if the height of the HTML and the
body elements are also set to a hundred
percent a simple way is to use the VH
unit which stands for viewport height
one vh unit corresponds to one percent
of the viewport height and so 100 vh
means one hundred percent height you can
do the same with VW for viewport width
here you can see we've set the width of
the image to be a hundred VW one hundred
percent of the viewport width and you
can see that it resizes responsibly
another common responsive use case is
when you want an image to resize to fit
the smaller of the height or the width
of the viewport the the men unit
viewport minimum corresponds to one
percent of the viewport width or height
whichever is smaller if you set both the
width and the height to 100 v min you'll
get the effect you're after how about if
you want an image to cover the whole
viewport but without stretching or
squashing for this you can use the v-max
unit which corresponds to one percent of
the viewport width or height whichever
is greater so if you set both the height
and the width to 100 v-max the image
responsively resizes to cover the
viewport